I don't think it does all the time
especially because there's so many
things that can happen with any sort of
mental illness which makes it then a
problem when you're trying to explain it
to someone because they think oh like in
13 reasons why and it's not always like
that
sometimes they romanticize suicide and
depression in media and it's kind of
like a weird balancing act because
there's some mental illnesses that are
like seen as trendy or attractive like
anxiety or depression especially with
Twitter and stuff like that everybody's
like talking about it everybody's
retweeting about it it's not it's not a
trend it's an actual issue that people
live with every single day the media
doesn't portray like people like myself
I'm a black lesbian woman and I've dealt
with depression for a very long time
I've had suicidal thoughts I've
attempted it so for me to not have that
representation it's kind of hard for me
to relate to it well I think that the
media it doesn't portray it correctly
but I also think that they're on the way
up it's not good now but it's getting
better I think
the first time I attempted was in middle
school and that was kind of
understandable for my mom and my sister
because at that time we were going
through a really nasty divorce so when
that happened in middle school they kind
of understood that that's what led to it
and then two years ago I was drugged and
assaulted and that morning after I'd
been found it was such a traumatic
experience that my mom walked out and I
was just leaning over the balcony and I
remember breaking down crying because of
the fact that I thought I was gonna
throw myself so I think I was fortunate
enough to have a family that was very
understanding of everything I was going
through I feel like my family didn't
really understand a lot of people still
don't know like what's happened in my
past you know I was assaulted and
attempted and I was roommates with my
best friend she didn't even know no one
knew so I was handling it all internally
and now that they kind of know more or
less like I wish I just wish they would
have talked to me they would have asked
questions because I was in college just
all alone dealing with it by myself and
no one knew in my family my parents are
both immigrants my mom was a refugee so
everyone in my family struggled with
severe mental health and PTSD and we
just never spoke about it I think the
focus was make sure you assembly make
sure you you know get a good job make
sure you're surviving make sure people
see you as you know an American my
family had a really hard time wonders
even understanding that I was struggling
with mental health because they thought
I would wish something so well in school
and I have all these friends I'm hanging
out with them all the time how could you
have depression I mean I just don't talk
about it with my family when I told my
sisters that I was coming on here
they're like oh what's it about I was
like oh it's called suicide survivors
and you're like wait
did you I was like every time I go
through a depressive stage I just want
someone to hold me back and that's why I
don't think I actually want to die I
want to I want to as well I want to live
but it's really hard to do that every
moment that passed by I was like more
and more ready to like meet my maker I
saw it as like the easiest way out goes
somewhere where no one can find me and
then I'll be all right I don't know how
I was found
you know like somehow someway my friend
like had a gut feeling and then all of a
sudden like cops were like knocking on
my window in my car I went above and
beyond when I was trying to attempt me
and my sister she was begging me to go
to the doctor to tell someone and I was
very insistent like I don't want to
so in those moments yeah definitely I
did want to die but it was only because
I didn't know any other solution I
definitely wanted to end it all at the
moment that I was at I was ready to end
it and I made sure that I was in a place
where nobody could find me thinking back
to when I was sitting in that Creek and
everything that was going on I'm really
happy that I got up and walked away I
had kind of an epiphany when I was down
there in going in and out of
consciousness that my life is valuable
I think it is pretty selfish it's a
decision that you're making on your own
they're also not putting much
consideration into your family members
your friends and I think the effects of
you killing yourself and leaving your
friends and family behind could
potentially lead to maybe one of them
doing it my mother you know she was
going through a divorce right around the
time when I tried to kill myself and she
told me that she thought about it too
and that she wanted to but she knew like
when she saw me go through it that she
couldn't kill yourself could be selfish
because of the other people that would
be affected see I get where you're
coming from but I also for me the first
time I attempted in my mind that was
gonna be the option that would make
things easier for my family and even the
second time for me it was what was gonna
make things easier because in my mind my
family didn't want somebody that had
just been drugged and assaulted like
that's a huge burden to be carrying and
so I didn't want to place that burden
that I was gonna have to go through and
the financial burden of that on my
family I mean look at all of us I mean
we've all we all thought that was our
option we thought that that was the way
to go and afterwards we saw the benefits
of actually surviving and not having to
be dead and that's why I moved is
because I agree with everything that you
said and then I also remove you about
the family situation and about how
thinking about your family and thinking
about the people that love you I
recently just got reconnected with my
biological father
if I would've ended my life at 16 that
would have never happened
he would have found me and he would've
got the horrible news like oh yeah your
daughter committed suicide at 16 so that
aspect of it does make me feel like yes
that is selfish because there are still
people who I don't even know who love me
I agree with you saying
suicide can be selfish because it's such
a huge trauma to a lot of people but for
people going through that actual moment
what I felt most frustrated about was
okay people don't want me to die people
want me to live but I don't know how I'm
going to live because at that time I
didn't know if I could even start a
medical transition I didn't and I know
trans people in Korea are not even
employed so how am I even gonna get a
job I need I need some kind of support
to continue living but that was so hard
to find
I think I once was like very unhappy and
very dark on the inside and I always
portrayed being that friendly outgoing
person now I'm genuinely happy on the
inside because I've worked so hard
equally as hard as I do on my physical
fitness with my mental health and being
happy to me is feeling at one with
yourself which is sometimes just being
alone which is okay and I feel like
people make that like oh you're alone
all the time you're excluding yourself
no it's not that I'm taking that space
for myself to get to be happy for me I
feel like happiness is a lot of pressure
like I don't want to measure myself on
one emotion I feel like there's the
spectrum of different things you can
feel you can feel upset you can feel
happy you can feel depressed and for me
it's just I don't need to be in a
constant state of it so I think when we
talk about happiness it gets confusing
because I think generally we're just
saying are you okay and to me that's
different
it really saddens me that I am standing
here because I know it will disappoint a
lot of people around me because they all
all want happiness for me and sometimes
I feel like I need to be happy because I
need to fulfill those people's wishes
but it's not actually that it's supposed
to be for my own sake and like it it's
also like every day I struggle with a
lot of things like being trans being a
non-us citizen who is trying to
immigrate here having family issues so
it's okay to not be okay yeah like you I
am forced to be happy it's okay and
that's the thing like if you would ask
me a month ago I would have been
standing over there with you it's such a
wave but like the past week it's been a
good week for me but I mean a month ago
I would have been right over there
I think in terms of the statement it
gets better
there's kind of a little tagline that
comes after it that's but it does take
time you don't heal right away sometimes
you're gonna be in that dark place and
you have to write it out and you just
have to find that willpower inside
yourself and it's very hard sometimes I
feel like something that I was told a
lot growing up was that that it doesn't
get better and that life gets worse and
all those things like it totally gets
better everyone was wrong take those
risks like have faith in your own
abilities like push yourself as far as
you can go that's what I've been doing
for the last three years and it gets
better I feel like for me I'm in a
position of privilege because it did get
better for me I had access to resources
I had health insurance so I could see a
therapist I have a job so I have
financial stability I don't think that
everyone gets that I don't think that
everyone is dealt the same hand I'm on
the side of agreement here I think that
time heals all earlier I said I wasn't
happy but compared to where I was when I
tried to kill myself tremendously
improved I'm not in that deep dark state
of mind and I do want to live there's
not I mean I still struggle with it but
I don't want to die and I guess that's
all that matters our society is so
adamant about you know making it a point
that well you have to get better quickly
instant gratification graphic right you
have to get better quickly or you have
to act like you're at least better
quickly and you don't it's okay to act
like you're not okay for that time being
but as long as you get out of it and get
there and take your time and do what you
need that's all that matters
[Music]
it gets better everyone